¿Cómo lo hacemos?
Ante todo, buscamos a jóvenes
entusiastas, comprometidos y educados de esos mismos pueblos.
Hombres y mujeres.
Los llamamos "equipo Balika"
–balika significa "la niña"–.
Es un equipo que creamos para las niñas.
Y una vez que hemos reclutado nuestro grupo de voluntarios locales,
los entrenamos, les enseñamos y los guiamos.
Así empieza nuestro trabajo.
Y lo primero que hacemos es identificar a cada una de las niñas
que no va a la escuela en ese lugar.
Pero lo hacemos de un modo diferente y con alta tecnología,
por lo menos desde mi punto de vista.
Cada miembro del personal tiene un teléfono inteligente,
con la aplicación "Educate Girls".
Y esta aplicación tiene todo lo que nuestro equipo necesita.
Tiene mapas digitales de los lugares donde realizarán las encuestas,
la encuesta misma, todas las preguntas,
y pequeñas guías de cómo realizarla mejor,
de modo que los datos nos llegan en tiempo real y son de buena calidad.
Armados con esto,
nuestros equipos y voluntarios van de puerta en puerta
a cada hogar, para encontrar a cada una de las niñas
que quizá nunca fueron inscriptas o abandonaron la escuela.
Y, como tenemos estos datos y esta tecnología,
podemos saber muy rápidamente quiénes son las niñas y dónde están.
Porque cada uno de los pueblos están geolocalizados
y entonces podemos construir esa información
muy rápidamente.
Una vez que sabemos dónde están las niñas
podemos empezar el proceso de traerlas de vuelta a la escuela.
Y este es nuestro proceso de movilización comunitaria:
empieza con reuniones en el pueblo, reuniones con el vecindario y,
como ven, asesoramiento individual a los padres y las familias
para poder lograr que las niñas vuelvan a la escuela.
Esto puede llevar desde unas pocas semanas hasta varios meses.
Cuando las niñas ya regresaron al sistema escolar,
trabajamos con las escuelas
para asegurarnos de que estas tengan la infraestructura básica
para que las niñas puedan quedarse.
Esto incluye un baño separado para las niñas,
agua potable,
las cosas que ayuden a que no se vayan.
Pero todo esto sería inútil si nuestros niños no aprenden.
Por lo que llevamos a cabo un programa de aprendizaje,
que es suplementario,
y es muy, muy importante,
ya que la mayoría de nuestros niños son estudiantes de primera generación.
Eso significa que nadie los puede ayudar en casa con la tarea,
no hay nadie que pueda apoyar su educación.
Sus padres no saben leer ni escribir.
Por lo que realmente es clave
que realicemos el apoyo escolar en las aulas.
Así que, este es nuestro modelo,
en cuanto a encontrar a las niñas, traerlas
y asegurarnos de que se queden y aprendan.
Sabemos que nuestro modelo funciona.
Y lo sabemos porque
una reciente evaluación de control aleatorizada
confirma su eficiencia.
Nuestro evaluador encontró que en un período de tres años
'Educate Girls' pudo hacer regresar a la escuela
el 92 % de todas las niñas que estaban excluidas.
(Aplausos)
Y, en términos de aprendizaje,
nuestros niños se superaron de modo significativo
en comparación con otras escuelas de control.
Esto fue como un año adicional de escolarización
para el alumno promedio.
Y esto es enorme,
si piensan en un niño de una tribu que ingresa al sistema escolar
por primera vez.
Así que tenemos un modelo que funciona;
sabemos que es escalable,
porque ya se está llevando a cabo en 13 000 pueblos.
Sabemos que es inteligente,
porque emplea datos y tecnología.
Sabemos que es sostenible y sistémico,
porque trabajamos en asociación con la comunidad,
en realidad, lo lleva a cabo la comunidad.
Y trabajamos en asociación con el gobierno,
por lo que no se crea un sistema paralelo de entrega.
Y como tenemos esta asociación innovadora
con la comunidad y con el gobierno, y este modelo inteligente,
tenemos este sueño grande y audaz,
que es resolver el 40 % del problema
de las niñas excluidas de la escuela en India en los próximos cinco años.
(Aplausos)
Y Uds. pensarán que es un poco...
Ya saben, como puedo pensar en hacer eso,
porque India no es pequeña, es un país enorme,
con más de 1000 millones de personas.
Tenemos 650 000 pueblos.
¿Cómo puedo estar aquí
diciendo que una organización pequeña
va a resolver el 40 % del problema?
Es porque tenemos una percepción clave,
que es
que debido a nuestro enfoque con sus datos y su tecnología
el 5 % de los pueblos en India
tienen un 40 % de niñas excluidas de la escuela.
Y esta es una pieza grande del rompecabezas.
Lo que significa que no tengo que trabajar en todo el país.
Tengo que trabajar en ese 5 % de los pueblos,
unos 35 000,
para poder resolver una gran parte del problema.
Y esa es la clave,
porque estos pueblos
no solo tienen la gran carga de las niñas excluidas de la escuela,
sino también muchos otros indicadores relacionados,
como la malnutrición, el retraso en el crecimiento,
la pobreza, la mortalidad infantil,
el matrimonio infantil...
Al trabajar y concentrarnos en esto,
podemos realmente crear un efecto multiplicador
en todos estos indicadores.
Y esto implicaría que podríamos hacer regresar a la escuela
1,6 millones de niñas.
(Aplausos)
Debo decir que he estado haciendo esto durante más de una década,
y nunca encontré a una niña que me dijera:
"Quiero quedarme en casa;
quiero cuidar del ganado;
quiero encargarme de mis hermanos;
quiero ser una niña novia".
Cada una de las niñas que conocí quiere ir a la escuela.
Y eso es lo que realmente queremos hacer.
Queremos poder cumplir esos millones de sueños.
Y eso no cuesta mucho.
Con nuestro modelo, encontrar e inscribir a una niña cuesta unos USD 20.
Para garantizar que aprende y brindarle un programa de aprendizaje
son otros USD 40.
Ahora es el momento de hacerlo.
Porque ella es, realmente, el mayor recurso que tenemos.
Soy Safeena Husain, y educo a las niñas.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)